dobbs one minute to midnight thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
next a memorial for author and radio
host studs turkle who died on october
31st at the age of 96.
participants include walter mosley
publisher emeritus of the nation victor
navaski and musicians steve earle and
alison moore the program contains
language some might find objectionable
the event hosted by the great hall at
cooper union in new york city is two
hours
all right welcome everybody welcome to
cooper union and to what is going to be
a celebration tonight of stud circle
[Applause]
i'm laura flanders host of grit tv and
radio nation grit tv is a new show you
can find online on satellite on cable in
new york and just about any place you
can get more information at grit
org and there are cards out there for
you to take home and peruse at your
leisure
um we are going to celebrate tonight
we're going to celebrate a man who
documented a century really but way more
than that to me he really changed
journalism
um
he told his stories not by
heading to the
libraries in ivy league colleges or
talking to the people wandering the
halls of power he did it by talking to
what he described as uncelebrated people
and not really so much talking in fact
as as listening to them he was born in
1912 here in new york uh graduated
university of chicago in 1932 and he set
out he said thereafter to swallow the
world
and he gave it back to us i don't want
to say regurgitate because that doesn't
sound good
but he gave it back to us in a way what
he did was introduce us to each other
um as an interviewer myself i always
found incredibly frustrating
reading his books his oral histories
because he would have such tiny short
references to his questions
and when i got a chance to interview him
which i did a few times i would ask him
about his
interviewing technique because i wanted
to steal from it of course
and i would ask him about what he what
his questions were about music and he
would tell me what his friend mahalia
jackson had to say about music
and i would ask him what his attitude to
documentary
uh film or documenting history was and
he would tell me what lucy jefferson's
idea about those things was she's a
project dweller came to chicago from
mississippi
i once interviewed him about his own
autobiography that he had just authored
and when he found out that my father had
been interviewed by him in the late 60s
he spent the entire interview talking
about my father
um which was lovely but for the
listeners who didn't know my father it
was sort of false advertising um
that we were going to talk about studs
so studs was
really a teacher
for me in the art of listening and it
was only when i went to his books
that i
learned his
approach
um
he wrote it down and he wrote it down in
his first division street i won't take
long but i do think it's important to
as a journalist
to tell you what i think is so
powerful about what he did he said i
realized quite early in this adventure
that interviews conventionally conducted
were meaningless
conditioned cliches were certain to come
the question and answer technique may be
of value in determining favored
detergents toothpaste and deodorants but
not in the discovery of men and women
it was simply a case of making
conversation
and listening
and he went back to lucy jefferson and
talked about a feeling tone
i think what studs created was a
listening
tone
and it was as much his tone as his
choice in who to listen to
today is an interesting day to be
talking about studs because i don't know
about how many of you um watched msnbc
this morning
meet the press i mean nbc this morning
when they they were
handing over the host chair of meet the
press from tom rocker to david gregory
[Music]
and tom brokaw asked david gregory who
he'd learned from and they both said
they'd learned from tim russert and they
both said they'd learn from each other
and i kept waiting for somebody to say
which what studs would have said which
was
i learned from the american people
i learned from the accidents in history
that i got to be part of i learned from
the
shove he would say in the bus line or
the angry radio listener
that's who studs
said
made
his education
and whose studs gave back
to all of us so
at nbc once when questioned by my
friends at fair the media watch group
why they interviewed who they
interviewed which is to say only
essentially straight white men working
for conservative organizations or the
government in washington dc
um
they said well we go where the power is
to talk to the pertinent people
and i think what studs taught us was
there are a whole lot of pertinent
people we should be listening to
and talking to who are not
straight white men working for either
the government or for right-wing
organizations in washington
and i think right now he would be saying
we should be listening to the buzz
that's happening out there in the
country
there's change coming from his hometown
of chicago to the white house for sure
but there's other change coming from
chicago today
how many of you have heard about the
takeover
of the american windows and doors
company
[Applause]
a plant was taken over by its workers on
friday
when american republic windows and doors
was cut off by its
bank bank of america bank of america
who've received 25 billion dollars from
us the taxpayer and bailout money
they said we're going to let the workers
go
and the workers instead of saying okay
well we'll have a miserable christmas i
guess there's nothing we can do
they said you know what we're going to
take over this plant
and they took over that plant and they
said there shouldn't be a bailout for
them and a shutout for us
and they're there right now and people
are lobbying and rallying with them so
in the spirit of stud circle and
everybody here today i want us to send
our our listening vibes out to the
people of chicago and particularly the
workers at republic window and doors
find out more information when you get
home and let's get to this program we
have an extraordinary series of people
who are going to be speaking and they're
going to speak sequentially i'm going to
sit over there everybody knows
on the stage here i'm going to sit over
here with the express purpose of
catching your eye
when you hit the five to seven minute
limit all right
but let me introduce first off wonderful
performer
celebrator rallier radio host steve earl
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see
this is a song about heroes
and uh the heroes end up having to be my
heroes but
it's my song
feel free to insert your heroes wherever
you choose
within reason
but there's uh that's not to say that
all of my heroes are in this song
studs turkle could have been in the song
he's my hero because he said
i hope for peace and sanity
the same thing
[Music]
i probably met studs later than anybody
on the stage
and i remember i sort of uh
gained a life in an audience for the
first time in what became his hometown
chicago illinois
my dreams came true there and
i remember when he retired from radio i
thought well
i can't be that big of a deal because i
was never interviewed by studs turkle
but then a friend of mine named tony
fitzpatrick had a party and
invited me
and i walked through the door and stud's
turkle sitting by the door and tony
introduces us and
he held out his hand and he said
so tell me about yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
and i just
[Applause]
with what's happened i heard through
tony the last time he went to see studs
but
that he just said he was hanging on to
see what happened with this election
because he knew something was getting
ready to happen he wanted to be around
to see what we all thought about it
and i
i wish he was here just so
he could help us keep these guys on us
and make him keep their promises because
i know
so i'm gonna sing this because i wrote
this uh before another inauguration
seems like a thousand years ago now
it's christmas time in washington
[Music]
things not get worse
republicans drink whiskey knee
back here lucky stars
they said he cannot seek
there'll be another more fdrs
i sit home in tennessee
[Music]
staring at the screen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rise against
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to us now
[Music]
i followed in your footsteps once
it's back in my traveling days
somewhere i feel to find your trail and
i'm stumbling through the haze
but there's killers on the highway now
and a man can't get around
so i stole my soul
for wheels that road and i'm stuck here
in this town
[Applause]
[Music]
from paradise
[Music]
maybe he can't help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
us now
[Music]
woody
there's foxes in the henna house
there's cows out in the corner
[Applause]
[Music]
listen to
[Music]
straight to hell
[Music]
[Applause]
going
[Music]
[Applause]
martin luther king
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come back
to us now
[Music]
all right
[Music]
steve earl everybody steve earl steve
will be back with allison moore at the
end of the program
next up we have
american book award winner author
victor navaski author of naming names
matter of opinion editor and publisher
emeritus of the nation magazine victim
of asking
[Music]
thank you it's great to be here
um you know we heard about how studs
was a great listener and i think it was
charles kuralty said when stud listens
everybody talks
and uh i
but the truth is that's only the half of
it i want to
read you something
that i wrote for the nation about studs
but in the course of it to
take liberties as
anyone who was on studs program would
learn he would do and so i'm going to do
so i remember the first time i met studs
i'd written my first book it was about
robert kennedy's attorney generalship my
publisher sent me on a tour to
washington where i was on a program i
got up at six in the morning i was on
their morning news show the guy said to
me
so tell me mr navaski would you say the
kennedy brothers were the rover boys
and i looked at him i didn't you know i
should have known what the rover boys
would but i said no i wouldn't say that
and he said thank you and that was the
whole interview and then my publisher
sent me to chicago and i arrived at wfmt
in in the studio that studs had
and you get there and he's got your book
and he's underlined it with in yellow
throughout the book and he starts in and
he says
listen to this listen to this it says
page 37 he reads page 37 in a way that
reads all kinds of meanings you didn't
know we're in there that you said he
said now
compare this to page 182 and he goes to
182 and he's got that and he says how
could you
see on page 37 that he's going to have
this on 182 and he's some brilliant new
insight that he credits you with and you
leave there on a high i can't begin to
express what it was like my friend bud
trillin said to me before i went out
there he said if the guggenheim people
knew what they were doing instead of
giving these 25 000 fellowships they
would give people a hour on the studs
turkle show and then they would really
leave there as writers who understood
what it was all about and
studs could be funny too he in the late
1970s
uh he had a long history with the nation
magazine which katrina vanden heuvel is
going to tell you a little about i think
but he was a reader a writer or a
cruiser with us a promoter for the
magazine he served at masters master of
ceremonies at nation dinners and i
remember when i first got there there
was a dinner honoring his great friend
carrie mcwilliams who is a famous great
editor of the nation magazine and i had
gotten there at the same time young
hamilton fish got there and ham was our
publisher and ham was the grandson of
the reactionary congressman hamilton
fish who roosevelt made famous as martin
barton and fish and they were they were
a very retrograde group and studs looked
at ham and he couldn't let the occasion
pass without commenting on ham's
reactionary grandfather he said it just
goes to show the more things stay the
same the more they change
[Laughter]
and studs was a man not just of great
taste he was a man of tastes and when we
called him he became a very modest five
thousand dollar shareholder in the
nation when we got there and and this
was before there was such a thing as a
fax and we had to get a signature by
midnight at the end of the first of the
year and we called him and asked him if
there was a we were going to send him
secretary shirley sue led out there
asked him if there was anything he
needed and he said
yeah from new york she's coming from new
york here
so she came and brought him what he
needed a pastrami sandwich on rye from
the stage delicatessen that's what
that's what he said he needed he can't
help it okay
you know the late leigh hayes who was
famous as one of the weavers folk singer
used to say that uh
if it weren't for the honor of the thing
he just assumed not have been
blacklisted
well
studs appreciated all of the honors that
were heaped on him and cuny including
his pulitzer prize for the books that
his great publisher andre schifrin
published and andre gave him the ideas
for his books
he but i have to tell you something not
he was proud of nothing more than being
blacklisted from his own television
shows studs place he was kicked off the
air from it early on
so he undoubtedly
he only
of all the people here would have gotten
a kick out of a story the new york times
ran a few days after his death
here's the story the times ran and and
it was brought to my attention by james
who tried these who used to produce cbs
sunday morning and it featured studs
along on the show along with john
leonard and others a friend of studs who
alas died also here's here's a quote
from the story by edward rosstein in the
new york times
on monday november 3rd
the times wrote
uh
in an appraisal of mr turkle and his
work
you would this is a quote from the
rostein article you would have thought
that he was a secret terrorist or
communist and the cold war was still on
look more closely rostein wrote and it
becomes less clear where his liberalism
slips into
radicalism uh the
rothstein noted that studs wore
something every red every or something
red he had this red checkered charity
war
wore something red every day to affirm
his attachment to the working class
this is a quote from the new york times
a few days after studs died
think of that you can imagine studs
turkle riffing when he reads that
to be blacklisted when alive and
red-baited after death too good to be
true
[Applause]
the ultimate comment not so much on
studs is on the culture he so valiantly
resisted
on more than one occasion studs would
compare a journalist to if stone george
seldes or lincoln steffens to
indicate his highest accolade
uh studs was more than a journalist but
his name now joins the ranks of those he
admired i want to just read you
something he wrote about carrie
mcwilliams who also he would cite
he reviewed his book in the nation and
he said about terry because it's it's
his language that i want to con
community
he's saying
the fact was he's talking about this
issue carrie uh
guest edited from the nation called how
free is free and it was in the 50s
mccarthyism was on he says the fat was
really in the fire the magazine was
bitterly and constantly assaulted as the
kremlin's baby especially by the new
leader in commentary mr mcwilliams is
devastating as he cites chapter and
verse of the abominable role played by
those cold war lick spittles apparently
there is no sense of shame in those
precincts in the 1970s they picked up
where they left off in the 1950s
how new is neo
well that's studs lincoln stefans
iaf stone george seldes carrie
mcwilliams all of the greats he joins
them and he adds on his own special zest
thank you very much
thank you victor
just by way of reflection studs turkle
was on the air in chicago
fmt from 1952 to 1997.
that's the kind of no
term limits i can get behind
katrina vandenhovel editor and publisher
of the nation magazine
[Applause]
[Music]
your peachy studs would bellow through
the phone
i loved it when studs called me that who
else would have
whatever happened to that incomparable
adjective studs would ask me
and he'd always tell me
to pass that feeling on to quit your
mother who's probably too young to
remember the adjective though she
deserves it too
my mother by the way considers herself a
very minor disciple of studs
she's tried her hand at oral history
edie was one of her books
and one day she and studs met up she
wanted to interview him but the grand
master of oral historians had come
equipped and he pulled out his taping
equipment
after all as studs like to say
i tape therefore i am
and he'd add
only one other man has used the tape
recorder with as much fervor as i
richard nixon
[Laughter]
well in my mother he met someone with
about as much fervor for taping as
richard nixon
so they sat for a while that afternoon
like friendly cowboys in a high noon
standoff
two people so used to listening getting
stories out of people who didn't even
know they had stories to tell
and i think after a bit studs decided
the hell with this
i'll just start talking
america's preeminent listener was after
all a preeminent talker and a great
interviewer
interview he was
studs as victor has said was had a great
long wonderful relationship with the
nation as reader writer
promoter
and one of my happiest moments as editor
was when with the measure of hutzpah
and moxie i called studs to ask if he at
age 92 would write a tribute to his
friend pete seeger who was about to turn
86
and he happily agreed you see i had seen
pete and studs together just a couple
years earlier
at fdr's stomping grounds hyde park
stubs loved fdr in the new deal
way before it got fashionable
he loved how it gave dignity hope and
work to ordinary people
after all studs worked
for the wpa's federal writers project he
was a child of the depression and he
wrote about when he learned fdr died
he leaned on a lamp post
and wept so studs was in hyde park that
november to get her four freedoms medal
and while his award was for freedom of
speech he could have qualified for any
one of those four freedoms so studs
regaled the crowd that afternoon
there were monkey muks there was senator
robert byrd the one guy studs like to
say who said bugger off when bush came
around to try to sell that idea of the
war
and studs regaled everyone with tales of
imagining arriving at hard park and
asking fdr mr president could you fix me
one of your superb martinis
and he took special delight in being
there that november day in 2003
because it just happened to coincide
with the dedication of the henry wallace
visitor center
spitting distance from the fdr library
so studs reminisced about working for
and voting for henry wallace so fast
forward two years later studs writes a
tribute to pete seeger and let me quote
just briefly from his wonderful piece
because it's as much about studs as it
is about pete
this is studs it's hard to think of pete
seeger as an elderly gaffer because the
boy in him the light remains undimmed
the night when i first encountered the
four wandering minstrels of the almanac
singers with a cold chicago beauty
at two in the morning my wife heard the
doorbell ring
i was away rehearsing the first play in
which i'd ever appeared it was waiting
for lefty of course
and there at the door with the four of
them the first was a bantam freckled red
haired an elfin he handed my wife a note
saying these are good fellas put them up
for the night and putting them up was a
rough assignment even for a depression
near a social worker what would the only
spare bunk be in a murphy bed that
sprang from the walls freckles announced
himself as woody guthrie
the second was an ozark mountain man
named lee hayes the third was a writer
millard lampell
the fourth somewhat diffident more in
the background was a slim jaw of 20 or
so fretting around with his banjo he was
pete seeger
and studs closed hail pete at 86 still
the boy with that touch of hope in the
midst of bleakness
that is studs a touch of hope in the
midst of bleakness
a hope monger
and for someone who lived through so
many isms if he had an ism as his good
chicago friend gary wills i think said
his was under dogism
and all the while with tape recorder in
one hand martini in another store for
the radical idea of the long memory how
could he not vigilant vigilant optimist
that he was for a man who was born the
year the great black boxer jack johnson
was denied passage on the titanic
and who lived to see an african-american
from his beloved chicago on the verge of
the presidency
last time i spoke to studs it was in
july
and it was to ask if he'd sign the
nation's open letter to obama holding
the candidate to his promises and
possibilities
sure stud said sign me up but he needs
to counter punch
studs bellowed
remember his roots as a community
organizer
and studs especially wanted to make sure
that obama was moved was pushed to
launch a new new deal
how he would have celebrated those
workers in the sit down strike in
chicago yesterday
so as stud said of pete seeger i say of
studs
there ain't no one like him
love the man he was peachy
i did
[Applause]
about that about that tape recorder
katrina i did once ask studs how did he
sort of um
avoid the problem of people being
intimidated by the tape recorder and he
said i would hit it a little
just to put it down and in its place
gary young is a columnist for the
guardian in the uk and a regular
contributor to the nation magazine he's
also the author of two great books no
place like home and stranger in a
strange land encounters in the dis
united states
thanks very
much back during the early 80s studs
was standing at the number 146 bus stop
in chicago when two
with two yuppies
and two yuppies who he had seen
several times but who had
uh failed to notice him and studs was an
institution in in chicago everybody knew
who he was and he said
when i interviewed him this was the
guardian he said it hurts my ego he said
but this morning the bus was late and i
thought this was my chance another rest
i'm going to read in his voice his
account of
dealing with these two yuppies he said
to the man who was all decked out in
brooks brothers and gucci shoes and he
said labor day is coming
and then
said well that was the wrong thing to
say as though he didn't know already and
he said so the man looks towards me with
such a look of contempt it's like now
coward has just spotted a bug on his
collar and he says we despise unions and
i thought
so the bus was still late said studs and
i've got a winner here and suddenly i'm
the ancient mariner and i fix him with
my glittering eye how many hours a week
do you work i asked and the man said
eight
and i said how come you don't work 18
hours a day like your great-grandfather
did you know why because four guys got
hung in chicago in 1886 fighting for the
eight hour eight-hour day for you
well he was scared said tugs
and the bus was still late and i've got
this guy pinned up against the mailbox
and he just couldn't get away
how many days a week do you work i went
on well the bus did eventually came and
i never saw them again but i think that
every workday morning his wife was
looking at me from the 15th floor of
their flashy apartment block to see if
the madman was still there
now
studs
told a a fantastic story and while
we all
and i will too give testament to his
listening he also could talk the legs
off behind donkey too that story took
actually 25 minutes to tell because
stats would veer off into you know some
story from 1920 or 1930 and you know i'm
a bit like laura trying to kind of
keep some focus here because it's an
interview for a paper and i'll say so
about you know the bus stop and the god
i'm coming to that i'm coming to there
worried about it so it's like jazz
improv talking to uh uh talking to stars
so he loved to listen and in a way
listening was his vocation and he liked
to talk and actually those
two things were became incredibly or
increasingly problematic as he got older
because
he's a man who liked to listen and who
became
quite deaf so actually when
when he would talk he would um he would
shout quite a bit but as soon as i
arrived and i was you know no one
to him
um to interview him
he came out from a back room in his
apartment and immediately he wanted to
talk to me about an article i'd just
written for the nation about obama then
he wanted to talk to me about tony blair
and why was he um holding bush's coat
then he wanted to talk to me about ken
livingston and his chances um in the
mayoral elections in london
an incredibly
curious
and uh lively man this was last january
um 95
and
around his um
apartment the first thing he did
actually
uh after after talking to me about my
national article was offer me a whiskey
which i thought was incredibly generous
and um
around him there was books on einstein
orson wales
katrina hepburn
and a host of others and you can tell
this guy's mind
was racing like his stories were racing
he was
in the very best way all over the place
just kind of like a magpie just picking
um picking things up and then you know
meshing him together in his whole his
own unique way
and the stories that he told
you were never quite sure one you know
you tell the story about mahalia jackson
and
um him uh the blacklisting story and how
they said you know
are you
for communism and he said if the
communists were for were against cancer
would i have to be for cancer you know
is that is that uh is that
what it's come to and he would tell a
story with mahalia jackson and the next
time next moment he would be telling a
story about one arm charlie who was a
guy with no teeth
um who and apparently one arm who um
who
ate graveyard stew and i asked him what
graveyard shoes and he said there was a
thing that you ate when you dip milk in
uh uh you dip bread in milk to make it
mushy if you if you had no teeth and he
would he was
talking about one arm charlie and um the
seattle strike of 1919 and he would keep
throwing out these references and of
course i'm both uh well there was the
thing about keeping him focused but
there's also an issue of um
uh of vanity not least because he had
said you know people don't know anything
they can't remember anything so i would
just nod as though i knew what the
strike of 1919 was and then you know as
soon as i got back to my hotel you know
straight onto wikipedia and everywhere
else trying to find out what he was
talking about and and that was another
thing that was great about him was that
he
assumed you should know this stuff
and if you don't know then find out
because it's part of your history and
it's uh and it's uh it's part of
our
story
now
um
i
work for the um
uh guardian and the nation and while i
was interning at the guardian we were
sent
off
the guardian has a a program for young
non-white journalists and i was on this
program and we were sent off to these
very very small towns in the north of
england where there are very few black
people and
none in the newsrooms and there were
three of us in these small towns having
these kind of terrible experiences and
one of my
one of my friends whose name was randy
an indian guy had called me while i was
out doing some core reporting and i came
back
and you could tell that the copy editors
had been waiting for this moment and i
came back and they said um
you've had a phone call gary some and i
said okay and he said they say here gary
randy at work
but we don't know whether that's a
message or a description
and they
fell about laughing and um two days
later i went out with my
two colleagues uh randy and um ken sarah
we were son of
the late nigerian um
uh environmentalist and playwright and
ken sorry this isn't a sophisticated
comment and there'll be many people who
might be offended by this in the
audience but actually it was pertinent
to our experience at that time
we were eating in this chinese
restaurant and ken sarwee was said to me
what does both of us said
what is it about white guys they get to
a certain age and they just feel the
need to be so [ __ ] boring
and and it really did speak to what we
were going through and
the point here is that
the more powerful you get
the less you have to listen
the more we can all come up and talk and
the more status you have
and that
that was what was great about studs and
with obama and people keep talking about
well this is going to be a fantastic
role model for young black men and that
may well be true i hope it is true but
they talk about it as though people are
limited to looking at role models as
people who look like them and that some
young white kid might not
find obama as a role model or that i
might not find starts
as a role model and i really do
as a
32 or something um
journalist
um
to
meet and read and know about a man who
has a voice and yet is interested in
other people's voices
um who is generous with his time who has
maintained both a spirit of
battle and
a sense of
humor who
who told these fantastic stories and
somehow managed not to get in the way
of them
who was
a voice
for the voiceless
that that for me is a real role model of
something i might be
in my life
if come
60 i can listen half as much as he did
and learn half as much as he did and be
half as curious as he was then i
will feel like my life has been well
served so i'm going to finish with a
quote from e.m foster
um because it really
speaks
to me to to what touch was about studs
was about it says i believe in an
aristocracy of the sensitive
the considerate and the plucky
its members are to be found in all
nations and classes and all through the
ages and there is a secret understanding
when they meet
they represent the true human tradition
the one permanent victory over cruelty
and chaos
to me studs was that victory
and he was that popular aristocrat the
one way in which one might speak of that
without being a contradiction and he
represented the very finest in human
tradition thank you
very young
[Applause]
next up a man who is uh curious and who
has enabled many important stories to be
told long-time publisher of studs turkle
andre schifrin director and
editor-in-chief at the new press
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you and thank you all for coming
here studs would have been really
delighted to know that you were here
that we had this occasion he had planned
himself a memorial which will take place
in chicago at the end of january and he
planned it very carefully but it was for
the people in the midwest garrison
keillor george willis and others who
were old friends and admirers and he did
not know that we were going to have this
tonight and i'm delighted that we have
and i think he would have been very
pleased
there are many other people who wanted
to come and talk and there are people
throughout the world who were very
eager to to speak up for about studs the
observer in london today uh has a column
by one of their columnists who says that
reading studs is division street had
really had an incredible impact on his
life it had changed the way he'd seen
america it had created an america that
he wanted to see
and i think that's something
that we need to remember that for many
people overseas
studs was the voice of america in a way
that our government was never able to to
to do
and he showed a population in its
diversity in its reality uh that the
official historians and certainly the
official propagandists had no interest
in discovering
i've worked with studs for over 40 years
there are people here like dan terkel
who of course will speak next who have
known studs all of their life some
people here have met him only recently
but i think all of us had very much the
same feelings about him and for me
during those 40 years it and the 14
books we worked on together uh the major
feeling was one of astonishment he
always surprised me from the very
beginning to the very end
as victor has said
when i first met him he had just been
interviewing an author and i saw him
underlining every other page of the book
that he had just read
and i understood later why someone like
harrison salisbury would say that he was
much more interesting on studs book on
stenz's program than he had ever been in
any of his books
studs was able to get the best out of
people
and he did so with an extraordinary
range
he was a remarkable musicologist as a if
you've ever read his book and they all
sang you'll see how he can compare
mahalia jackson with an aria from mozart
or with the music of ravi shankar in a
way that many musicologists would be
very proud uh to to discover um he was
with all of the the foxiness and the uh
camaraderie that has been described he
was a remarkable intellectual
uh he understood the country
he understood its past he understood its
culture
in a way that very few people i've met
have ever been able to do
um
after his programs which is how i heard
about him i asked him to do division
street to try and do a book about
ordinary people and he was very amused
that a new yorker should come to chicago
and suggest that he do a book about a
village
because i had just published jan
mirdell's report from a chinese village
and i thought it would be interesting to
have an american equivalent that is to
see
through the eyes of ordinary folk how
their lives had changed in the previous
decades
and so studs did this so brilliantly and
so interestingly that it was clear that
he was
really going to be our historian that he
would write a history of america from
the 1920s to the present
coming up with the stories that many of
you have read and also with many of the
secrets
that people had often
kept from themselves
i used to say that studs
could get people to speak openly and
frankly even when they had lied to
themselves
and one of the things he was proudest of
was some woman in a chicago housing
project who at the end
of their interview said my god i didn't
know i felt that way
um and he was able to bring people out
of themselves in that fashion
um even people who certainly uh he
didn't agree with
uh and um the idea that was
tried by rossetting to say he was just a
propagandist looking for uh folks who
would reinforce his views couldn't have
been wronger
he
interviewed the man who dropped the bomb
on hiroshima
he was proudest of one of his interviews
with the man who had been in the kkk and
had finally changed his way of life when
he realized how the kkk was being used
by uh the people in the south who wanted
to keep whites and blacks separated from
each other
so he was able to go to people who he
didn't agree with in the slightest but
who he respected
and when young interviewers asked me
what was his secret i say you know that
you can read it in the text actually it
is his extraordinary respect for the
people to whom he spoke he wasn't
looking for a sound bite he wasn't
looking for a quick fix he wanted to
know really know how they felt even if
they didn't know themselves
it's interesting
victor has talked about this unpleasant
rusting
article in the times
and he
was able to make light of it in a way
that i wouldn't quite because i think
it's such a sad comment on our
on our society that the mccarthyism that
so really ruined his life
as a performer he was thrown into the
wilderness by the mccarthy period by his
courage and refusing to knuckle under
that it should have surfaced again two
days
after his death
and the rusting article which said in
effect that studs was trying to impose
on ordinary people his marxist view of
alienation and so on
was actually very interesting because it
made me realize what was at the bottom
of a lot of this mccarthyite thinking it
was a kind of denial of reality
just as the mccarthyites in the 50s
couldn't admit that countries like china
wanted to go to the communists so
rostine could not accept the idea that
we were not a country of happy working
men
the myth that the right has always
believed in
and that their
unhappinesses were were brought in by
outside agitators and therefore it was
the messenger who had to be punished
as he tried to do i think not very
effectively with studs
but studs was the opposite of denial
he was someone who wanted to affirm and
who did so extremely well
he stayed
with me through 14 books including
the years when we left random house over
basic differences
as to what publishing was about he
refused many offers of vast amounts of
money to go elsewhere and stayed
with the new press which we then started
and is responsible in many ways for
our having survived these these many
years and
really had a very good period of time
thanks to his book in great part
so i have a real
debt to him for that loyalty
but as a country i think we have a
broader debt to him as someone who has
taught us how to really understand what
the country is like to look at our past
to admit to all the failings that others
have tried to cover up and to understand
what america was about thank you
[Applause]
i just want to
how are we doing celebrating studs are
we still in celebratory mood you have a
little bit of celebration left over
because i would like to just take a
moment to celebrate the new press and
andre schifrin for the incredible work
that they do
[Music]
next up we have the self-professed
policy wonk and project planner also
stud's son dan turkell thanks for coming
joining us at the
podium that's dan turkel
[Music]
[Applause]
greetings from chicago folks
glad to see you here
like my father i'm an agnostic
or in his own words a cowardly atheist
so i try to keep an open mind
i don't know if there's a heaven or a
hell or an afterlife
but i'd like to believe that once the
physical being makes that grand exit
from the planet
that the spirit will live on and
maintain a presence among us
if indeed my dad's spirit is present in
this hall he'll have come full circle a
virtual round trip between
new york and chicago with numerous side
junkets in between
96 in a fraction years ago he entered
this world just a short spit up the road
from here
213 avenue a
corner of 13th street
the building's still there
he was the youngest of three brothers
the baby of the family
his father sam was a mild-mannered
tailor loved and renowned for his
gentleness
his mother annie despite her tiny
stature was a woman of towering presence
who viewed the world through pincenez
glasses
with a perpetual cynical squint
whenever she spoke
and yiddish was her first language
she tended to add more than a dash of
color to an already colorful tongue
even her english was known to be
volatile
his eldest brother meyer was a scholar
who encouraged my father to read and ask
questions
benny the middle brother was a bo vivant
a ladies man who introduced my father to
the earthier aspects of life
so there you have it a quick synopsis of
the early years of louis turkle
pre-studs
fast forward a bit
a well-to-do cousin encouraged the
family to resettle in chicago in 1921
when my father was nine
annie and sam managed a rooming house
for the first few years then in the late
20s they held forth at a men's hotel on
the fringe of downtown chicago
among the hotel residents were craftsmen
railroad hands dishwashers and retirees
many of whom were self-educated
they were
wobblies
other socialists
and also company men
otherwise known as capitalists with
holes in their pockets
when they'd congregate in the lobby on
sundays vigorous debates would ensue
often fueled by
liquid lubricants
these were folks who inspired my father
to become an activist they were his
earliest mentors along with eugene debs
clarence darrow albert and lucy parsons
and of course his father sam and his
brothers meyer and benny
then there was law school
having had visions of clarence darrow
instead he found himself face to face
with contracts and torts
it wasn't his bag
he somehow though managed to graduate
but never had the desire to practice
during the depression he managed to find
civil service work but also became
involved with the chicago repertory
group a group of performers who were
kindred spirits
they believed in community theater
often appearing at union rallies in
behalf of various humane causes
apparently a number of cast members
shared my father's given name lewis
the director noticed that he was showing
up for rehearsals carrying a thick book
under his arm
james t farrell's studslanigan trilogy
so one day he said to my dad
hey uh
studs come here
the name stuck
so there you have it his formative years
so now i'd like to focus
on the one watershed event that really
set the course for the rest of my
father's life the blacklist
joel mccarthy bestowed upon my father a
wonderful gift
as perverse as that may sound
had tail gunner joe in his minions not
launched their merciless crusade chances
are that my dad would have been a very
different studs turkle
chances are
he'd have never become the free spirited
messenger of goodwill
holding forth on chicago's wfmt radio
for
45 years
chances are he'd have never hooked up
with andre schifrin
who with his relentless coaxing and
cajoling
encouraged my father to help create
along with the legions of the folks in
his books
a massive body of work for the ages
my dad would never ever
consider compromising his humane values
that's what led to the untimely end of
his budding tv career
in the embryonic days of network tv
there was this weekly show out of
chicago known as studs place
featuring a colorful array of characters
and set in a modest neighborhood diner
the dialogue was improvised and the show
had wide appeal
one fateful day
in 1951
a pr man from the network showed up at
the studio
he had with him a thick stack of
petitions my father had signed in
support of various progressive causes
such as the anti-fascist league and
various civil rights groups
the pr guy wasn't happy
we're in trouble because of you
don't you know that communists are
behind these petitions
[Music]
without missing a beat my dad responded
with another question
if the communists came out against
cancer
would we automatically be
for cancer
the fellow was not amused
so much for stud's place
but nevertheless
my father loved to boast that he never
met a petition that he didn't like
on the other hand my mother ida a woman
of equally strong convictions with an
eternally graceful presence
never met a demonstration she didn't
like
a number of years ago they retrieved
their respective dossiers from the fbi
as it turned out my mother's file was
much thicker
i don't think my dad ever quite got over
that
so
our family did have some lean years
throughout the 50s and 60s
my father had become an enduring
presence at wfmt but the station still
had a very limited audience so nobody
got rich however he loved what he was
doing by the mid-60s the station had
established a magazine called
perspective
which sometimes featured written
transcripts of my father's interviews
they ultimately caught the eye of andre
schifrin the rest
is history
as a conversationalist my dad had an
uncommon knack for making everyone feel
at ease so
as an oral historian he didn't really
ever conduct interviews in the strictest
sense
instead they were conversations
revelatory conversations
sure he'd ask questions all right but
there was nothing formulaic about them
the conversation was always a continuous
spontaneous flow
he'd get folks involved by revealing his
own frailties especially his mechanical
aptitude which was
legendary
whenever he'd struggle with his tape
recorder they'd lend a helping hand that
made them feel needed
on one such occasion my father was
interviewing a single mother with young
kids
once the conversation was finished he
played back the tape so the woman could
hear it
she sat absolutely transfixed so did her
kids
when it was over she declared
i never knew i felt that way
in 1999 my mother ida his wife of 60
years passed away they had shared the
same passions the same sense of social
justice
it was a delightful often exhilarating
life they had together
although sometimes tempestuous
to quote sean o'casey it was like
a lament in one year but always a song
in the other
thereafter my father and i drew closer
together excuse me
sure we had our issues as do many
fathers and sons not something to do
with our fragile male egos i guess
he needed me and i guess in my fashion
despite my own active life i needed him
too
like i said at the beginning
i honestly don't know
whether there's a heaven or hell but
just in case i would bet the tail gunner
joe and my father are not in the same
place
so here's to you pop
take it easy but take it
thank you dan
next up we have sydney lewis who worked
with studs turco for many years she
describes herself as having worked as a
waitress and administrative assistant a
bookkeeper etc one of her earliest real
jobs was in the program department at
wfmt where she says she was brought into
close daily contact with studs she has
yet to recover
i was just very very lucky
to get to work with him he was
well the first time i met him i was
waitressing i was waitressing at a
chicago club the quiet night and they
were having a benefit for the wobblies
and he and ida were in my section
so i went to get his dr and i had read
working i had loved working uh but i i
went to get his drink order and
where are you from how long have you
been here do you know what do you know
what the wobblies are you know who they
are
and he went on and on and on and finally
i said i i read working and i loved
working but i am working what do you
want to drink
that was sort of the uh report we had he
he cackled uh so eventually i ended up
working at wfmt radio and uh when people
would ask me what i did for him i would
say
nanny because
he he uh kind of had the energy of a
three-year-old a hyperactive
three-year-old
and he didn't like talking he loved
talking and the only time he wasn't
talking was when he was interviewing he
would leave his house in the morning
with his little blue jacket and hush
puppies he was heartbroken when hush
puppies were unavailable
and uh he always books rubber bands on
newspapers and he'd get on the bus and
make friends all over the city from
riding the bus and then he'd walk to
work sometimes i would be late and i'd
walk behind him and he would be just
talking narrating he life was to be
narrated the story trumped everything
and uh
he was exhausting
[Laughter]
um
people said you know he the the gag
about the cowardly atheist and he would
call it a gag but he he did understand
some religious concepts first there was
the word
always the word
and uh
and also he you know buddhists talk
about in the moment he was totally in
the moment
part of why his interviews were so
remarkable was because he was so fully
present
with his attention uh really embracing
you with his attention but he was also
in another moment uh in a historical
moment and he was thinking about
something next so you always felt like
you were having you know he was having
three conversations and you were part of
one of them and if you could keep up
with the whole thing you were doing
pretty good
so he'd get to work and you would always
know he was coming because first was the
voice the
elevator doors would open and you would
hear the voice that tom englehart made
me laugh we were commiserating after
studs died and uh tom said it's the only
voice he ever heard that has a cigar
coming out of it
and uh
and then he'd be coming down the hallway
and he'd come around the queen
he'd either say hey kid good morning how
are you doing or what do you hear what
do you say that's from a jimmy cagney
movie he must have said that to me 700
times
but you just you know you would he he
was very very very playful and the day
was always he might have uh a steel
worker or a social worker he might have
some celebrated historian a musician
there might it might be a little
conflict about because he he was listed
on the masthead as a free spirit
uh and a free spirit working in a
structure sometimes has conflicts so
that's where the nanny would come in
so he might have discovered some great
greek bazooky players who were coming
and he had to tape them right now and it
didn't matter if the chicago symphony
orchestra's quartet was already booked
in the studio and he sometimes he would
have little um frustrated fits or he
would where was that record that he had
to have because he was going to read a
story by alice monroe with beggar made
and he had to have this one particular
record where was it and so everyone
would drop everything and try to help
him find it and usually it was in his
office but uh his office was just
amazing it was pile everyone sent
manuscripts for him to blur people sent
books they wanted to be interviewed
people sent records it was you could
lose bodies in that office
and once oliver sacks came they had an
opera date they were going to go to the
opera together and he was waiting while
studs finished an interview
and uh he came out to my desk and he
said i've i put my favorite pen down
i've lost it
studs could find things but uh nobody
else could
uh it was sort of like being he was sort
of like one uh circus in a human body
you know and he was the ringmaster and
the trapeze artist and the lion tamer
and the rogue elephant and everything he
he was just remarkable to be around
his energy was so powerful uh i remember
bringing ida to visit him when uh he'd
had a quintuple bypass at 84 which he
was quite proud and he was in intensive
care okay so there's four beds three
occupied two people flat out and this is
the morning after and he's sitting up
wolfing some soup down because hey would
you like some soup would you like some
soup because he was always ever generous
and then he was looking at a blank
monitor he's like you know there's a
ball game on can can we can we get that
on the on that screen up there
he he he i leaned over just to tease him
and uh yelled into his ear
do you how are i said how are you do you
know who the president is and he looked
up at me he said mckinley
so you know he just he was really he was
like a musician like a jazz musician in
the way he he went about living there
was always room for the unexpected and
it was um
the real luck of my life to have been a
graduate of the school of studs he he
helped
me make sense of the world i don't know
how i will make sense of it without
um
he was really inept technically i know
it was a bit of a shtick
but it was true and also it was a good
thing in some ways because for example
he couldn't figure out how to work the
postage meter and every once in a while
he'd get riled about something and he'd
hear him muttering and they'd be
in
you know and sometimes those letters
escaped into the world
and always the next day there would be a
ruin regret so i when i learned that i
would intercept and say i'll mail it
i'll mail it don't worry and then the
next day did you mail that letter i'd
say oh no i forgot well maybe that's
just as well
he um
i got to listen to all these radio shows
people in chicago who were lucky enough
to hear that program there were people
who set their lives by that program at
10 o'clock which it was on for years
and the letters he would get from people
people felt that he belonged to them and
everyone who was ever interviewed by him
felt that they had a very special
connection with him more special than
anyone else's connection most likely he
could come to your home and interview
you and make you feel more at home in
your home than you had ever felt he just
he had a way it was
his real gift
i just listened the other day to a bbc
tribute by an oral historian really nice
and uh there was a
studs talking in it and he i'll just
read something that he said most of my
life
i've been listening to these voices and
trying to record as many as i possibly
can and i find that all of them at one
time or another have astonished me have
surprised me and i realized too there's
no such thing as a stereotype each one
is different
now they come from a certain society and
that very society may have influenced
their lives in the way they think but
each one individually is unique and
that's the aspect i consider somewhat
sacred
one of the people that he considered
somewhat sacred was peggy terry who was
appalachian and uh grew up during the
depression and he would often tell the
story about her where she as she said
she learned to cuss
her parents would take her to the you
know send the kids to the soup line with
their buckets and the guy would just
skim off the top so they would just get
this broth and and she'd ask him please
to dip down
and he wouldn't so that she she would
get there and she'd say dip down god
damn it so she could get some meat and
potatoes and
peggy was in several of his books her
father was in the clan for a while uh
she grew up in a very racist racist
environment and came to chicago and and
learned that it was just about who had
and who didn't and when eldridge cleaver
ran for president she was his vice
president candidate
uh studs interviewed her for hard times
uh and here's a little something she
said that has certain resonance today
i think that's the worst thing that our
system does to people is to take away
their pride it prevents them from being
a human being i don't think people were
put on earth to suffer i think that's a
lot of nonsense
i don't think it's right for a handful
of people to get a hold of all the
things that make living a joy instead of
a sorrow
you wake up in the morning and it
consciously hits you it's just like a
big hand that takes your heart and
squeezes it
because you don't know what that day is
going to bring hunger or you don't know
and then he went back to her dan and i
were with him
to interview her for will the circle be
unbroken which was the book he worked on
after
ida died which was really hard
he asked me to speak at her memorial as
you can tell i'm not used to speaking
publicly and i was very anxious i i said
i said well what what do you was there
something you want me to talk about and
he said about three minutes
[Laughter]
uh so anyway here's peggy many years
later dying of emphysema sort of trapped
in her house
she said i think one reason people are
so desperate about dying is they haven't
lived yet
all we do here is we try to see who can
get a little higher up the ladder than
the neighbor i think life is so
miserable for most people all the time
they're racing around like mad drunken
ants they're fearing dying
studs was not
fearing dying he was really
quite ready to go in most respects
i spent a lot of time talking to him
over the last few years i'd moved out of
chicago but i come back and uh
even recovering from a broken neck and
two months in the hospital he would
still exhaust me he one time talked for
five hours i'm not kidding
um
so where i said to him you know i was
talking about his dying and i said how
do you want to be remembered because
that was a question he asked everybody
in will the circle be unbroken and and
he did the gag you know cowardly atheist
i mean curiosity did not does not kill
this cat
and uh and then i said well not the gag
really and he said he paused he said i
think curiosity
he said the key word is why
and i asked him if he was afraid at all
and he said i kind of for a moment jesus
what's going to happen
there's ego involved here too
will i be missed
who will miss me and for how long
and he laughed because i went
and immediately started crying
sorry
he said that's the other thing that's a
question
so the books there's something but even
so will people talk about you
there's a fear of course fear of the
unknown
i envy those who believe because they
feel they will meet their dear ones well
you can't beat that nobody's going to
win the bet who are they going to pay
the bet too that's the one thing you
can't bet on
you can bet on citation on seabiscuit
but you can't bet on a hereafter
i use the speech what you do now is the
hereafter this moment what you do if it
does mean anything does live after you
it'll be nice good for your not alter
ego but after ego to be remembered i
think people want to be remembered to be
remembered for something
that's our friend mike lavelle who's a
steel worker who said who know i ever
lived i pound my hammer into an ingot of
iron bam to make a bump in it my bump
and i said what would you want your
biggest bump to be and he said i don't
know when people write these certain
letters
about how their life has been influenced
that i reached somebody i like bumps
like that
you all are a nice bump
[Applause]
next up
we're very very honored to have with us
stetson kennedy one of this country's uh
pioneering folklorists the author of
many books including the jim crow guide
and the clan unmasked he's the co-author
of south florida folklife stetson
kennedy welcome to the microphone
[Applause]
[Music]
well
like i used to say down south where i
come from
i'm just so proud to be here
uh someone handed me uh two pages just
before it came out from backstage
uh listing other people who have spoken
here in this uh cooper's union
and starting with the name of john brown
and i said to myself you know this
this fight for freedom
and social justice
and world peace had no beginning
and it's going to have no end
so so i think it's all together fitting
that we gather here today and celebrate
the life and the work and the
legacy of stutter circle
i
[Applause]
stud and i had a great deal in common
including the wpa and the the writers
project
and the depression
and uh
i was in florida and he was in chicago
and i was supposed to be the boss of
zora hurston on the florida project
and he was up in chicago with richard
wright and a lot of other wonderful
people
and we just sort of knew we kept an eye
on what they were doing by long distance
it wasn't that much direct contact but
we were very much aware of what the
other was up to
and um
we were very much into collecting oral
histories and ex-slave narratives in
florida
and these of course we call them life
histories in those days we hadn't
invented the word oral history
but this was the beginning and
i've spent a great deal of my life
you know going from life history to oral
history just uh
and the same amount of study did and i
was highly honored that he included me
in one of one of his books
uh
i
i
want to put in a good word for oral
history in terms of of its veracity
because it's
something that comes not from someone
poking around the stacks
but from the people
the people who make history and do the
history do the fighting and dying
and the work
and
they are not only participants in many
cases but if they're not participants
they're eyewitnesses
so they bring to bear all of their
sensory organs and all onto the scene
so for that
reason
i can't help but feel that oral history
is here to stay
and
one of my books
speaking of true history i was going
around
before
howard then
my esteemed colleague here on stage did
his book on people's history of the
united states
i was going around saying that anyone is
brave enough to write a true history of
the united states they'd better have one
foot over the border
and so my compliments are perhaps off to
him
one of my books jim crow guide was
was
i couldn't find a publisher in the
united states
and i ended up with john paul sartre in
paris uh publishing it for the first
time
and you know senate publishers and some
yuppie cia agent came to me with waving
it in my face
and saying this thing hurts like hell
and said if you just repudiate it
i say it's a put up job
we'll make you financially independent
for life
and i said well if you can just point
anything in as it's
inaccurate
i'd be happy to collect it for free
and
he couldn't point to anything
i called a press conference exposing the
attempted bribe so i lived
hand-to-mouth ever since
[Music]
[Applause]
you know while i was wandering around
overseas uh something eight years
studying what other peoples were doing
and
and not doing
uh from time to time i would hear
someone say
you know the americans are the most
politically illiterate people among all
the industrial nations on earth
and of course that hurt
and i didn't quite know what to say but
i'm very
happy to be able to say here tonight
that after the recent election they
can't say things like that anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
you know at long last we've got a
president we can call our own
uh
studs uh my wife and i went up to study
his 95th birthday and he said among
other things that he thought perhaps he
had lived too long
but i'm certain that when he saw the
the outpouring and the coming together
that attended the barack obama at
rallies
that he was very glad as i am
to have lived so long
because
you know nothing like it ever was
and it's i hope just the beginning
he didn't live to see the inaugural
but
i have a feeling that
stud just may well be there we may not
see him but he'll be there with bells on
they they
inaugural in my opinion
nothing like it in american history or
or human history it's ever been like
this inaugural is going to be
so i know that we're all looking forward
to it
the the
what the the outpouring and the coming
together meant to me was that
that uh my life and uh stud's life and
the life of
there are thousands of other americans
who who spent their time uh working for
such a coming together
you know was not in vain
back in 1947 some ladies one of my
audiences said
she had been handing out pamphlets all
her life and going to meetings and
signing petitions and writing letters
she said in 47 was it all in vain
well i didn't know what to say to her in
47
but in 2008 she got her answer it was
not in vain
the
solidarity which we saw on election day
we've seen in recent history what the
very concept of solidarity
and the word
and the reality the manner in which it
was able to change the course of history
in europe
and i think that the
united states of america today we're
standing in need of that same kind
of solidarity
he um it's just the beginning
the um
we hear a lot of talk in our time about
trickle down
and in my opinion the meltdown is going
to be one sure thing for a trickle down
it's it's uh you know just begun i'm
hate to think
and i hope i'm wrong
but uh i'm
obliged to think that it's going to be
not on not just trickle down but it's
going to come upon us
[Music]
like a tsunami
and the only thing that we
can save ourselves
is by this
word solidarity
um
studs was there in the first depression
as i was
and someone was asking the recently what
it was like you know i didn't know of a
short answer so i said well it had to do
with the blue plate
and of course they didn't know what i
was talking about and i had to explain
that
back then the the blue plate
a vegetable plate you got four
vegetables
and a biscuit of cornbread and a drink
for five cents
and very much of america was living on
on blue plates
and you may have noticed on television
recently they've been inviting people to
buy mcdonald's stock
signs of the times
i um
you know studies books attest the fact
you know the manner in which americans
back then
by fortitude and suffering
and a whole lot of it you remember carl
sandberg's line about the
where the shapes of hunger wander and
the fugitives from pain go by
and coming back here to manhattan after
a half century absence
i was impressed by the fact that so far
in just so many hours i haven't seen so
many shapes of hunger
wandering and defeating the pain going
by i
know of course they're out there
but if this thing uh
develops it i'm afraid it will we're
going through an awful lot of it and
people back then were
prepared they were a lot closer to the
earth they hadn't been living in the lap
of luxury
uh this middle class that
and the working class is a
center of living has been such that
we're not very well prepared for what
may be in store for us and
we may find ourselves having to go to
the
the old timers and get some helpful
hints
um
you know i hate to stand here and sound
like an alarmist of any sort but
at the same time i can't help but feel
that you know
there are times
for alarm
you know like in the day of paul revere
and
in
this present moment of
2008
it's my impression that
no less of a crisis an emergency than if
we were an occupied country
occupied by a foreign power who has
strewn
minefields from coast to coast
biological and chemical minefields
and
we're just running on
the gas tank is
quite possibly empty and we're running
on
the vapor
i will to change the subject
i think what we're all about here and
what studs was all about certainly it
was a question of of caring
uh the spanish out of saying that uh
the left is the side of the heart
and the right is the side of the
spleenus
and i think it's a very
apt saying
you know
the one thing about the list of people
who've spoken here
at copper union
and i would just as an aside it was such
a long list of presidents and labor
leaders and african-american women's lib
uh
revolutionaries
uh have spoken here down through the
decades that
if it hasn't already be done i would
like to hear and now dub cooper union
the seed bed of democracy in america
[Applause]
[Music]
you know a half century ago used to be a
lot smarter than people are today
for example for example
that was of course before fox news and a
lot of other things
you know
got on the air
but
for example
we used to say that the republican party
is not exactly anti-black
it just doesn't care about people
and
this question of fox news and the the
again a tsunami of of
misinformation and dissonance that they
kept media have been donning into our
years i think it's
precluded you know a little more than
half of us voted for barack obama
and a new america
and so we have almost half of our
brothers and sisters to worry about you
know what's what's wrong with them
and what can be done about it
and
it's a question of
obfuscation and
diversion and
to an extent that i think they're
precluded from thinking clearly
uh
uh not not only not thinking cleared up
but above all not thinking critically
you know the einstein
you don't have to take it from me
einstein said that if we don't
if our institutions don't inculcate the
critical faculty
you know all is going to be lost
so i think we need to address ourselves
a matter of
learning how to distinguish between
information and misinformation
and
real goats from scapegoats
[Music]
i would say stetson if if if you and
studs turtle both were touched by the
wpa we could do with another one what do
you think
thank you so much
so once again i'll conclude on the note
that um
you know to me this thing the the
outpouring and the coming together uh
prove that uh
the american dream was not just a pipe
dream it's the first time we've had
concrete proof that we're not going to
go in other directions
and i think
and
we owe it to studs circle just as much
as any other american on the mountain
there's no one no other one before studs
who is responsible for helping to bring
that about
and it's so good that he lived to see it
thank you stetson thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i just want to say one thing studs would
talk to me sometimes about an event and
i'd say how'd it go and he'd say pretty
good i got a standing o so i hope before
we all leave we can stand up and give it
himself is standing up yeah tell him
just one anecdote
stetson kennedy everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you for all your work
next up author historian playwright
howard zinn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well
i first met studs in
1964
uh i had just uh
i just been
just finished
uh
seven years of living in the south and
just written a book called the southern
mystique
and so he was interviewing me for that
and i had the same experience that
has been described by
gary young and andre schiffer and that
is there he was with his book marked
marked all over i've never had an
interviewer like that
most of the interviews i'd had hadn't
read any book at all
i mean not only not mine book any book
so
in fact a few years later he came to
boston and several of us
went to meet him
and
he looked at me and said
the southern mystique and then started
quoting from it
which i couldn't have done but he was
amazing
but actually the thing i remember most
about the interview
was that afterwards i went back to my
hotel room
and i got a call
studs he says uh
are you busy tonight
i said
no he said well ida and i have tickets
to the pete seeger concert
uh will you come with us
so i did
anyway that was studs um
so we were all
grateful to him of course for
doing
this amazing job of bringing human
beings back onto the pages of history
pages have been
cluttered with the pronouncement of
presidents and
you know
you know
you know
having read a fair amount of history i
know what what's on the pages of history
and
yeah cluttered with the pronouncements
of presidents and and the exploits of
military heroes
and uh and studs
uh yeah brought people back onto those
pages and people with feelings people uh
brought their their anguish their joys
uh
when you pick up
the traditional orthodox history book
there are no feelings
in those books
everything but
so studs
did
an amazing job he
because he was
always concerned with
what you know what he called the etc of
of history that the people left out he
he
liked to quote bertold brecht because
brex was intensely aware of how uh
workers were left out of the stories you
know of the great uh achievements of
history you know uh and he would like to
quote brexton you know uh who built the
seven gates of thebes the when the great
wall of china was built
uh where did the masons go for lunch
and uh
those are the things studs
was interested in
uh
he had a complex
understanding of the world
uh he
he saw the double nature of things he
uh saw the double nature of work when he
when he introduced his book working
he says
to write about work is to write about
violence
violence to the body and violence to the
spirit
but also
uh
there's something else something besides
the daily humiliations that go with work
there's also somewhere in there striving
striving for something better
stud said that uh the central
event of his life was the depression and
of course you can you can see that in
his writings
uh uh you can see that in the compassion
in his writings that always in his head
were the pictures of the depression and
and
his own experiences
and then of course there was the war
and the black list
and he wrote this book the good war
uh
with quotation marks around it
which
i noticed some writer in the new york
times
didn't like
those didn't like the quotation marks
and i was always referring to the
quotation marks around the good war
uh
and because
uh
well because i was in in the war
and i i i was in what i considered the
good war and then when i came out of it
i began to think for myself
and i began to think for myself
i realized that there had to be
quotation marks around it
it was it was not until i read studs
memoir touch and go that i discovered
that his wife ida is the one who
suggested he put quotation marks
uh around
the good war
well i think of you know what what is
his
legacy to us what what can we learn from
him
uh
how could we be better people well one
of the things he learned from him is
this sort of incurable optimism not not
an optimism based on the idea that oh
everything is going to be okay
an optimism based on the fact that he
believed that
human beings are essentially good
maybe not all human beings
but enough human beings
to change the world
and that's all we want
uh that little modest aim
he
uh
seemed to have this
i spoke about it as this complicated
view
of the world is
seeing two sides and he acted out these
two sides in that uh that is the
seriousness
in you the humor he did not allow
his intense
awareness or the tragedies in the world
was to stand in the way
of his having fun
and
i think this is an important thing to
remember
i mean the fbi would visit him and he
would have fun with the fbi
they did not have fun with him
it seems that
a sense of humor is not a requirement
when you join the fbi
so i think that
you know as we
work struggle
to remove from power the the makers of
war
and the purveyors of greed
we should
learn from stud
you know
and enjoy ourselves the fbi men were
baffled
let's keep all those people baffled
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
next up
[Applause]
you can get all you can get more
information about everybody who's
speaking and all the participants after
the program there are flyers at the back
you can subscribe to important magazines
and make contributions to important
publishing houses and support
independent media that deliver people to
each other not just people to
advertisers
next up i want you to welcome walter
mosley author of the easy roland series
and life out of context from nation
books
[Music]
hello
everyone
um
you know i i i was asked to come
to to speak here and you know and i
really love studs and so i mean i
couldn't possibly say no and on the
other hand i felt like i couldn't
possibly
say yes i did say yes but i didn't i the
whole time i was thinking well maybe i
just won't go and there's a lot of
people on the stage you know you could
have lived without me and i figured you
know i could got sick or something and
it wasn't until
until this morning
that i finally decided that that that i
could come and the the problem i mean
there's a there's a few problems trying
to
talk about studs terkel the first one i
think it is kind of compromised by a a
short lyric by uh leonard cohen from a
song tonight will be fine
and lyric goes sometimes i find i get to
thinking of the past
when we swore to each other that our
love would last
you kept right on loving i went on a
fast
now i am too thin and your love is too
vast
the the thought of the studs i think of
studs this
very this giant
uh
thing in my life and and not just him i
mean because you know as you get older
people start to echo with other people i
like the word pedestrian
it is who we are at base those people
passing by in the street outside
the subway window on our way to work to
home
to some place ordinary and mundane and
yet at the same time
the place is exotic and extraordinary
because life is a kind of inexplicable
magic some of us very few i fear
understand the wonder of ordinary life
and everyday survival studs turkle was
certainly one of those special few
the last time i saw studs in chicago he
was in his 90s or just about
and we were being driven somewhere and
studs remembered that he had an
appointment in the opposite direction
and he said let me out here bill uh
there was a man driving the car
i see a bus coming
and he jumped out of the car kind of
like a little spider you know he jumped
over and the bus came and he jumped on
the bus he was 90. you know and i'm
thinking a bus you know and
i was amazed i was amazed i'd seen i've
seen since then but not not in chicago
it reminded me of of my my cousin dave
klieger who was a russian jew
much older than studs but i mean i you
know much he was born a long time before
him and
he was you know he was a communist under
the czars and a jew and the communist
party it wasn't good for him so he left
he came to america but
but but but he still loved being a
communist he didn't abandon communism
just because it in some ways abandoned
him
and so he went back in the 60s when he
was 72 years old and he and he spent a
week there and he came back and my
cousin johnny and i were visiting him
and you know we were young we're you
know 15 16 years old and dave you know
of course is 72 years old and he looked
at us and he said i went to the opera
and i told them who i was and they gave
me the czar's seat the czar's seat
he said and people were dressed normal
like you and me
and i remember that many years later
when i talked to studs because the most
astounding thing to me about studs was
it was always just you and me there was
never any hierarchy there was never any
difference you were never above studs he
was never above you he would not allow
that to happen in his life and it was
such a learning experience that that
vastness of course is you know when i
was 18 uh his book hard times came out
and i i read hard times but it was a
vast book it was the uh the mind that
that imagined it was much larger than
mine and and still is and
and i was just amazed by that and this
is you know of course i don't know him
yet i met him i forget maybe in 95 but
in 98 he interviewed me
and this morning i i listened to that
interview on you know on the computer
and and i was struck by a few things the
first was
how often i was silenced by his simple
and deep understanding of the world that
my book attempted to embrace
secondly how he knew the book better
than i did no joke i mean he was
correcting me i said well that's when he
put the cake he said no no it was
chocolates he was chocolates he put
chocolates i said oh yeah chocolates the
chocolates
and third how he ran over
in the interview
the interview was supposed to be half an
hour here's a rule you know it's a 25
minute interview a half an hour you know
things gonna happen well he did 48
minutes i understood that today because
they had to play it over two weeks
you know because studs had his he he
knew where he was going he knew where he
was going in the conversation and the
time limit that existed somewhere out
there in the world that was out there in
the world somewhere so that's okay we'll
do 25 minutes a day next week we'll do
another uh 14 minutes
that interview was more to me like a
lecture
in which the head master studs was
allowing me a deeper understanding of
myself
my work and the world that spawned both
me and my work haki marabhuti who runs
the black writers conference at the
chicago state university uh has a thing
called the lit the african-american
literary hall of fame
studs is the only white person in the
african-american literary hall of fame
i thought that was true but this morning
i called haki i said is that true he
said studs
haki's guy says you know i mean really
at one point he said he had a meeting
with these people in 1967 he said that
was the last time i talked to any white
people for 30 years
he said but he said to me this morning
said studs was a great man and you know
he was very happy i was coming here and
he wanted me to you know just to mention
him and you know in connection with
studs he said yeah i saw him a few weeks
before he died i kept in touch with
studs
you know and a lot of people you know i
mean it's interesting studs is kind of
confusing in a way the first time i met
him he took me into a room in which he
had
all of the tapes of all of the
interviews that he ever did
thousands and thousands of tapes of
these interviews and even though he did
talk to you know mostly to just normal
everyday people he was very proud of
some of the people he talked to who we
all know uh you know from my point of
view thinking about things martin luther
king jr james baldwin muhammad ali
mahalia jackson louis armstrong wendland
brooks dick gregory ralph ellison
but
but for me the most important thing
about studs
is a story he told me in that interview
he told me before but he also said it in
the interview that that we had in 98
he was at his house and he was sitting
in the dark
and a burglar broke in his house
and he explained the burglar he said the
first thing he said he said he was a
good looking
well-built young man
he came into the house
being a burglar of course expecting it
to be empty
and when he turned out the lights he saw
me sitting there
and then turned the lights back off to
hide his face
studs was 86 at the time
he said that the burglar was more scared
than he was
and they came to an understanding and
studs reached into his pocket and he
took out his money and he gave the
burglar his money
but before the guy left he said
but you know you're leaving me flat
broke i don't have any money left
and the burglar
gave him twenty dollars
back studs
[Applause]
a man who a man who uh listens and in
many ways uh
carries the tradition of studs turquoise
long-time columnist reporter
jimmy bressler
[Music]
thank you very much i'm flattered to be
here
i'm in chicago
one day i had something to do and i met
mike royko
who was the columnist there and he was
meeting turkle as they did an awful lot
of times
her tickle walks in and sits down at the
bar like an exposed wire
and
the nerves drink here talk there
cackled talk
and then
came he said he had a great treat for us
he brought in
esther
no eric nestorenko he was with the
chicago blackhawks hockey team
he was a licensed gorilla
in that business
hit people with a stick was his best
move turtle is bringing him back as a
poet
so we sit at the bar and nestorenko gets
up it's ricardo's bar
hard by the chicago tribune newspaper
and the sun times and he begins to
emote
and uh it was terrible it was painful
and uh there's this big guerrilla
what are you going to tell them you're
lousy i don't know
and the studs was elated he says isn't
he wonderful and that was stunts he
loved all the life so much that he was
he had the guy beaming and then he
finished it at which he
looked for
opinions mike royko said
alec don't ever let that son of a [ __ ]
and stick out of your hands
[Music]
that was
one other time we're at
the same place
and he comes in studs and we're having a
couple of drinks and that allende woman
from where chile was in town
and
you know the word fleece
came upon our minds but she had spent a
lot of time with with studs
and not just for being interviewed on
the
radio i think she wrote a bestseller
list that week at any rate uh
mike finally says what did you give that
woman
he said no no it's all right maybe we'll
have a drink
it's done what did you give the woman i
know nothing doesn't matter it doesn't
matter no it doesn't matter so i said
well why don't you tell them so at least
we'll know it doesn't matter fifty
thousand what is it about them we
fainted
she beat him out of fifty thousand
dollars that was his for the cause
whatever the cause was it wasn't ours
the bartender either but
that was
he was the
the last time i spoke to him it was hard
to i want to see him in the hospital out
there
and then
he's home and to talk to him he had
someone what you did you called and
someone answered the phone and you
talked to him then he turned and ran in
and told studs and you heard this
yelling
back
and then the guy would get back on the
phone and tell me what he said
the subject was one on which i
found interesting i've been
looking things up
that the united states hadn't been in a
war hadn't sent any
place troops after anybody who
wasn't
non-white
we haven't fired at a white since 1945
and
it it just came to mind with the why we
were talking was that uh
you know you're trying to put a black in
the white house at the same time as our
national policy has been when we go to
the most sacred thing a war we only want
to fight and shoot at blacks
so i thought it was a you know somebody
talked but was very hard because you
tell the guy on the phone
we
we shot a lot in iraq what would you
call them dusty's ass that's what they
are
so we i'd hear this yelling back yeah
that's all right or something then we
i'd ask him the colors of each place
where the fights were and he would he
would answer it and that's the last i
spoke to him and he
was spirited and yelling but it was it
was
they liked it when he you know you catch
them yeah they shot at another black
it was part of him was good
but that's gone now and he's uh he's a
loss
to uh
the hours in which you ever saw him the
energy was beautiful i mean it was a
knockout he'd come in at the bar and he
would start all over the place and he he
would tire people out i liked him best
at national political conventions
he he get in a place to be six or seven
people around him from some delegation
from south dakota and he started talking
to them and have them in a nervous be a
nervous wreck at the end of a half hour
you know you get some
some swede from up there coming in from
the fields where he'd been and he's
mopes into the bar and he runs in a stud
cycle and
i mean they don't know what hits him
and it was great that was
he could make you laugh he loved
laughter and he had charm and it
happened to be brilliant and a terrible
loss thank you
[Applause]
all right i want to thank everybody
who's spoken tonight jimmy breslin
walter mosley howard's in stetson
kennedy sydney lewis dan turkell andre
schifrin gary young katrina vandenhovel
victor nevascu and we'll go out with
another tune from steve earl and alison
moore thank you both and thank you
everybody
uh studs did interview bob dylan
[Music]
may your wishes all come true
may you always do for
[Music]
[Applause]
the
others
climb on like a run
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
space
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
grow up to be righteous
may he grow up to be true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
may you always be courageous
and upright and be strong
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
for more information about studs terkel
visit studsterkel.org
book tv sunday live at noon eastern in
depth with bill gertz defense and
national security